boys views go that one's not bad good
morning Hank it's Friday and I'm in
Bellingham Washington at a literature
conference so Mike over the weekend
there's going to be a question Tuesday
video not on Tuesday nerdfighters
pleased to believe in your questions and
comments
but today Hank I want to ask you a
question I was walking backwards Hank
we've been making videos back and forth
for more than three years and in all
that time we have never once discussed
red green and I'm starting to wonder
whether maybe that's because you are
guilty of a terrible crime now like the
preface to this story is that when I was
a kid I had a best friend
Nintendo Entertainment System Nintendo
and I went to everywhere together which
is to say that I never left the house
Hank there was nothing in life that made
me happier than when I would press that
NES power button and hear those fateful
words still sends a shiver down my spine
and of course we also had a dog a
miniature dachshund named red green who
hated me by the way Hank if you're
wondering I'm on my way to a bookstore
to try to secretly sign some of my books
ahead because you probably remember the
original Nintendo Entertainment System
had a plastic flap which you opened and
then removed a game cartridge or put one
in and sometimes at the end of a long
day of playing Zelda and Mario and
double dribble and blades of steel I
would remove that last game cartridge
and because I was not as good a friend
to Nintendo as Nintendo was to me I
would leave that plastic flap open now
Hank there can be no question that in
his life red green did many terrible
things he enjoyed biting children he
would pee on my bedroom carpet while
staring me in the eyes no look I'm a
staff pick but Hank in our family red
green is most famous for what I
discovered one summer morning when I
woke up dragged myself to the living
room and went to go play Nintendo you
see Hank red green had pooped in my best
friend the Nintendo I don't mean he
pooped on the Nintendo I mean he pooped
in the Nintendo I had left the plastic
flap open overnight and when I went to
put blades of steel in the machine I
discovered red poop
well the poop wasn't actually red it was
brown but it was from red now I ain't
the list of suspects for the crime is
really limited to our nuclear family and
read himself because it happened
overnight and the doors were locked now
I know I didn't do it because I loved
that Nintendo more than I loved my own
I'll just say it brother mom or dad is
certainly a possibility but I think they
like the Nintendo it minimized the
amount of time I was annoying though
plus it's just hard to imagine either of
our parents picking up dog poop and
inserting it into a Nintendo
inexplicable gazebo so far as I can tell
this leaves two possibilities one you
put the poop in the Nintendo or two in
the middle of the night red-green awoke
in a fit of violent jealousy backed up
to the Nintendo placing his bum against
its opening and proceeded to projectile
poop into the Nintendo unfortunately
Hank because I know just how nefarious a
dog red/green was I cannot discount that
possibility this means if we were
playing clue I would know the murder
weapon and the location it was red
greens poop in the Nintendo but even
after all these years I still do not
know the murderer Hank I think enough
time has passed for you to answer the
question honestly
did you put red greens poop in the
Nintendo or was red green some kind of
pooping genius Hank I expect your answer
on Monday